pad julien tessa et les autres elles
sont dix à briguer cette année le titre
de miss martinique
pour elle les shootings séance de
maquillage photos s'enchaînent à un
rythme effréné
les filles ont des cours de maquillage
découvre de maintien des cours d'anglais
des cours d'arts de la table et cetera
et cetera donc c'est une formation qui
mobilise quand même les candidats du 20
heures par semaine
donc ce n'est pas rien pour pouvoir des
plus variés dans un premier temps pour
l'élection de miss martinique et dans un
second temps celle qui doit être élue
miss martinique pour avoir cette toute
cette expérience à pouvoir se présenter
à l'élection de miss france une édition
2010 9 placée sous le signe du renouveau
une nouvelle équipe à la barre avec de
nouveau challenge mais toujours
difficile de boucler le budget on est un
peu bien parce que nous avons eu la
participation du comité martiniquais du
tourisme
nous attendons toujours la réponse de la
collectivité territoriales de la
martinique
donc nous sommes dans les starting
blocks en temps d'attentes cette réponse
est bon ça prend un petit peu de temps
mais c'est vrai effectivement que on est
un peu limite
on aurait souhaité effectivement d'art
ont un budget comme celui de la
guadeloupe de la réunion est de tahiti
ils sont mieux dotés ça n'a rien à voir
un corps sain dans un esprit fait ces
jeunes filles ne mise pas que sur leur
physique
elles ont aussi des messages à faire
passer j'ai vu tout au long de ma
jeunesse la jeunesse martiniquaise qui
qui n'arrivaient pas à prendre confiance
en soi qui qui avait qui avait peur de
de se mettre en avant qui avait peur
d'affronter d'affronter le monde de la
voile au monde d'aujourd'hui le monde de
l'entreprise et je trouve que que le
concours de miss peut aussi servir à
inspirer j'ai voulu participer
premièrement
les jeunes les jeunes martiniquais pour
leur donner en fait plus envie de faire
également en fait comme je fais tous
bords du haut niveau alors donner plus
envie de faire du sport et des études
l'élection se tiendra le 4 octobre
prochain avec comme parrains et
marraines ronald rubinel écran soldats
en attendant les filles elles voc vers
leur destin l'une d'entre elles sera
désignée reine de l'année